hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
can you believe it's already the final
week of season X if you're new around
these parts in this series we meet up
weekly and go through all the map
changes in fortnight and put together
theories about the future which could
also be the past thanks to time trouble
so slap code a tomorrow in the shop
think about subscribing to get me to 1
million subs that a bit pretty cool and
let's go through all the minor changes
that have happened this week so today is
the day that Gotham leaves fortnight but
which Tilted will return in its place so
go cancel that because it's stayin until
the end of the season well that was
anticlimactic yeah Gotham's here until
the end
a real update this week was over at
dusty the rocket now complete has an
indestructible control panel which is
completely interactable each few days
the signal becomes a little clearer so
go on go touch it every couple of days
you know you want to this could be your
calling in life he could be a NASA Space
engineering in never knew we also
commented on the corrupted mechs last
week and sure enough a few hours later
the Brutes which fell from above
exploded on impact if you remember
season 3 this is just like the meteor
showers back then another bit of
nostalgia
[Music]
here's something interesting for weeks
I've been stood here waiting for the
chalkboard at dusty to update for a clue
or a map or a destination for the rocket
to go well an awesome guy in my discord
karma jika told me that in creative
there is a prefab of this building and
when you put it down
something is indeed written on that
chalkboard and check this it's a
blueprint of the vault this can be found
on the island over by the anti-gravity
area the Nexus it was used prior to the
vault opening but I'm taking this as
confirmation that the Nexus is going to
be destroyed if we look at the original
rocket trajectory it flies through the
vault to claim the power as everything
is repeating itself this season should
the rocket follow this path again it
will destroy the orb when passing
through it could this be how the season
ends the Nexus and the rocket collide
before I go over the top with these
theories you guys noticed last week that
the race track above starry suburbs is
now unavailable but it does promise to
come back so I guess we just stand and
wait hot watch you were our hero but I
believe Kevin is coming for you this
week so rip the dream but it's okay
we've got hot watch 2.0 now rush of 2.0
no change over here this week but hang
on was there always a graveyard here
this has suddenly become a bit spookier
than I expected
let's see what happens here next week or
next season if it makes it that far buzz
of 2.0
oh and have you looked in replay mode
this week if you did you'd see these
cassettes how retro is that okay let's
check the audience please use the poll
in the top corner have you ever owned or
used a cassette to listen to music and
yes they were still around when I was an
infant and yes I'm so old
while these cassettes are great for two
reasons firstly in save the world the
same event is going on right now with
time travel and time-bending
record players vinyl players they're
popping up to replace modern servers and
PCs it's damn freaky in facts
holy oh this could be part of the same
timeline so let's add it to today's
theory but the second reason to find
these bad boys is to unlock a challenge
in the overtime missions next week the
outs of Time missions will be available
from Tuesday the 8th of October until
Sunday the 13th so let's get ahead of
this and find out where they are right
now if you remember last season we had a
challenge to unlock extra skin variants
for singularity well this season we're
doing the same sort of thing for the
scientist here's the six locations you
need when the challenge goes live first
get your butt over to paradise our
moisty or whatever you call it these
days on top of the hotel is a yellow
cassette tape from 1989 which was also a
great year by the way next to go over to
Kevin's island and look in the back of a
pickup another cassette waiting for you
going off to retail row and in the book
star is yet another cassette open starry
suburbs is another one this one can be
found directly below the spire it's on a
bed next go to Gotham and in front of
the cinema is the penultimate cassette
and the final tape can be found down in
greasy Grove tacko dumps over to the
restaurant and on one of the back tables
is your destiny this will unlock
something next week but if you don't
know what it is I shan't spoil it for
you but remember these are not live yet
these are just in replay mode at the
moment so I think that's everything is
that right like usual hit me up on
Twitter if you see something I've missed
I'm atom grenade over there now now is
the time to plan out a story this one
has a few spoilers for save the world
but mostly that timeline is the same as
our own
but this is your chance to click off if
you plan on playing save the world
before this season ends be ready let's
do this last week we talked about saying
goodbye to the island this week it's
about merging timelines and building a
new beginning what if I told you a
message had been in front of our eyes
all season long building for years
seemingly in the background from the
beginning we looked on as we brace for
impact
seeing worlds collide and darkness rise
you better watch out we cried as pirates
came with treasure and x marks the spot
as time flew forward the future is yours
for the taking but ultimately we are out
of time
these are the tag lines for each of the
seasons when added together they give us
a message but one part of this message
is more important than we first thought
x marks the spot season x marks the spot
in time where the future is defined but
we are now out of time and soon the
island will be no more but this isn't
the time for sorrow we've heard stories
of the seven dimensions seven timelines
with branching paths and slightly
different events but only two of these
we know of in person the world of battle
royale and the original four night we
call save the world in save the world
the Guardians of Earth have survived the
storms which have killed 98 percent of
the world's population as hope dwindles
and meteor hits just like here on our
island but this is where the timelines
part while we watch the cube lift an
island those in another world fought a
god who resided in that cube a demon of
Darkness both worlds survived fought
nightmares both saw the desert return
both took on evil versions of themselves
and both saw the meteor return now
here's the important part
have you ever wondered where those V
books come from dr. Vin de Minh a
brilliant scientist from an alternate
timeline but sadly he died before this
story began but just as we have seen on
our island the timelines are changing
meteors are suspended without reason
items are passing through dimensions
without warning those trying to save the
world used dr. Vin de man's teachings to
time-travel and reset their reality but
here's where the timelines entwined the
original scientist dr. Vin de man is
still alive lost in time somewhere out
there and the only other brilliant
scientist we know capable of creating a
time vending machine is the scientist is
dr. Vin de Minh the real scientist is
save the world and Battle Royale about
to combine well I finally get another
thick skin Oh seriously I need penny in
my life damn girl
oh sorry getting sidetracked the season
will end with an event
which spans every phenomenon we've ever
seen reliving all live events but with
the twists from other dimensions
sadly the island can not handle this
much destruction and time-bending
shenanigans and the Nexus is finally
destroyed bringing an end to time travel
and resetting this story but where will
be our new home this is our final week
here so dance with Hut watch one more
time and get hyped for a brand new
season and hopefully the greatest live
event in fortnight history
[Music]
[Music]
and if you're wondering what happened in
saved the world well they thought they
fixed the timelines when in fact they
remain unstable all I know is that we
lose in the end what do you mean you die
please stop telling everyone how they
died the last thing we heard from those
guys was the cube joining forces with
our heroes she hired the cube
I'm going home early okay so that's it
for today I'll put together every single
map update of the season into a ten
minute video later this week to watch
before the event starts you don't
realize how many things you forget like
I forgot frozen Greece he ever existed
and that was this season on screen now
are the people who were kind enough to
use my code and a Mario in the phone I
shop I really appreciate it you guys are
leggins to me I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade let's meet up again next week
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]